ingénieur c'est aussi pour les femmes
pour certaines de ces 80 élèves de 4e
c'était une découverte leur collège
participé à la septième journée
nationale des sciences de l'ingénieur au
féminin il y à une minorité de femmes
qui font ce genre de métier et pour dire
que c'est aussi accessible pour les
femmes on connaissait juste des hommes
l'écart nice où j'ai jamais connu de
fermer génère comme témoin des femmes
ingénieures sahara nédélec et chef de
service chez bout de travaux et public
elle se déplace dans les collèges
franciliens depuis quatre ans c'est très
important parce que moi je me rappelle
quand j'ai commencé je il y avait
peut-être 5% des femmes dans ces métiers
là et
c'est pas normal normalement dans les
entreprises il doit y avoir une
représentation équitable de la société
les femmes sont autant compétente que
des angles le collège de mort pas
participé pour la première fois cette
journée trois heures d'échangés avec des
questions sur le salaire sur l'égalité
entre hommes et femmes et sur les choix
d'orientation peut-être qu'elle ne se
questionne pas encore mais nous on
aimerait voilà que elle se questionne
qu'elle commence à se questionner
parce qu'effectivement en fin de 3e fera
faire un choix d'orientation s'est
jamais long et difficile quand on aime
ce qu'on fait et des fois bien
effectivement j'ai aussi expliqué qu'il
ya des moments on peut se tromper on
peut faire un choix se trompe et puis
changer c'est pas grave on a droit à
l'erreur cette journée concerne près de
20000 jeune fille sur l'année 2017 2018
les femmes n'étaient que 27% dans les
formations d'ingénieurs